Ngoài Mét Am Tham tăng bẩy năm 2020, sở sư dựa thành phố chiming đã có văn bản định gỡ con hoàn thành phố,
vì bán nhân dân các phường, sá và các đơn vị linh quan tăng cường xử lý tình trọng lần chiếm lòng đường.
Bì hay, theo đó, 2 chung tâm còn lý hạ tần và điều hành xấu thông được yêu cầu giả sát,
đánh ra chực tự đô thị và đi xuất lắp thêm camera giám sát tại các vị trí phút tạp, hỗ trợ kiểm tra,
sự phát tự động. Thực tế tại nhiều tướng đường Trung tâm, ô tô dừng, đô sai quy định,
hàng xong bài bán lấn chiếm viềm kéo dài. Các sự kiện như đam cưỡi, đam tham,
tật kết vật liệu xây dựng cũng sẽ về uống tác, mất nghĩ quan đô thị và tìm ở VWC tài nạn.
Chứ tình hình đó, sự xây dựng đề gỡ tắc mức kiểm tra, tôn tra và sự phát nghiêm khác,
đặc biệt tại các khu vực trợ chuyện thống, công trường, bình việt, khu trề sức và các định nắm sào thông.
Ui bán nhân dân các phường, sá được yêu cầu phối hợp xử lý mạnh tay vì phạm lòng đường,
việc hệ vì một định bún bán và đối xe như một hàng tại diễn bán từ phát.
Đông thời vẫn động quyết dân và hỗ kinh dân tôn thủ ch het tự đô thị và tăng cường
biến chuyên các quy định phát lợp phy ra thông và đô thị.
Vyệt nghiên kiểu lắp đặt camera giám sát là mức tiếp theo của dế phát phát gội được nhiều địa phương xin 2,
nhằm tạo mức được phát trong quán lý đô thị vàng công nghệ.
Đây cũng là nỗi lực thiết thực trong việc lợp lại ch het tự vẻ hệ,
bảo đam ăn tòn giáo thông và gó phần xây dựng Mỹ quan đô thị,
phục vụ tất là ý chung của cậu đăng.